président le prix à payer face à la rue
un documentaire signé Michel cottaï
Patrice Duhamel qui sont avec nous ce
soir si toi aussi Pauline pallier qui a
réalisé ce film avec vous comment réagir
face à la contestation sociale lorsqu'on
dirige un pays faut-il faire preuve de
fermeté de souplesse d'un peu des deux
quel est le bon équilibre des questions
qui sont bien sûr au cœur de notre
actualité je vous présente tous nos
invités Michel cotta donc bienvenue à
vous et merci d'être avec nous
journaliste politique écrivaine Patrice
Duhamel journaliste politique vous avez
donc coécrit cette série documentaire en
trois volets président le prix à payer
ici le volet 1 face à la rue il y aura
aussi le volet 2 intitulé face à la
société et le volet 3 face au terrorisme
Jérôme cordelier est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes de rédacteur en chef
au service France du point qui est donc
notre partenaire sur cette émission et
Franck l'ouvrier bienvenue mère et l'ère
de la Baule vice-président de la Région
des Pays de la Loire ancien conseiller
en communication du ministre puis du
président Nicolas Sarkozy et c'est
important de le préciser ce soir Michel
cotta après avoir interrogé tous ces
responsables politiques que l'on voit
dans ce film avez-vous réussi à vous
forger une opinion un avis sur la façon
dont un président doit gérer la
contestation avez-vous vous-même des
réponses aux questions que vous leur
avez posées non impossible non
pas être à leur place
et on sait que quoi qu'on fasse
on peut se poser des questions une
partie de nos interlocuteurs nous disent
attendez un moment donné il faut bien
reculer
faut reculer négocier circuler
et puis d'autres qui disent
comme Nicolas Sarkozy je leur ai dit je
n'irai pas et j'ai pas bougé mais ça
fait aussi des des semaines de
contestation donc je crois que le cours
des choses
un porte plus finalement alors il y a un
moment donné où il y a une ouverture un
moment donné on la trouve pas et au fond
le talent d'un c'est de trouver
l'ouverture au bon moment et restez
faire ou reculer négocier négocier c'est
un peu reculer nous dit Edouard Balladur
dans votre film vous avez réussi à
savoir s'il y avait une méthode
miracle non si elle existait je pense
qu'Emmanuel
non moi j'ai retiré deux leçons la
première c'est que les présidents qui
ont eu des bons capteurs et une
expérience de terrain
ils ont quand même mieux réussi que
d'autres et ou des premiers ministres
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence les
présidents parce que c'est quand même
eux qui sont à la manœuvre quand ça va
très mal c'est c'est voilà c'est eux qui
prennent les décisions et la deuxième
chose c'est que
ils doivent trouver le bon moment pour
parler bien entendu de savoir quoi dire
au bon moment mais surtout le timing de
dans l'action et dans la parole je sais
pas ce que Franck aurait suggéré à
Emmanuel Macron mais c'est
extraordinairement important avec ce
qu'on voit dans le documentaire
notamment général de Gaulle à 6 jours de
distance il se plante le 24 mai 68 et le
30 mai il fait les 4 minutes 30 qu'il
fallait faire que tout le monde
l'attendait et à 16h31 mais les
événements de 68 sont terminés
[Musique]
c'est peut-être le premier élément
indispensable en chacun de ces hommes en
l'occurrence qui sont présidents de la
République c'est qu'il faut de
l'expérience et on le voit bien
l'expérience elle compte aussi bien pour
la décision immédiate que pour la
décision à venir ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est bien
évidemment un sens de la réactivité et
on le voit notamment en mai 68 général
de Gaulle qui passe du référendum à la
dissolution en utilisant justement le
troisième point j'irai indispensable
parce qu'en fin de compte tout le monde
autour de ça c'est la constitution de 58
c'est à dire c'est le mode d'emploi
alors le mode d'emploi vous pouvez
rentrer par la porte par la fenêtre par
le résistance par où vous voulez mais à
chaque fois on en revient toujours à
cette règle de base qui est celle de la
conscience 58 alors où on utilise la
dissolution on utilise le référendum où
on utilise la négociation voilà il y a à
chaque fois changement de Premier
ministre et alors là il y a quelque
chose qui est intéressant je pense dans
l'évolution du temps peut-être qui se
démode un peu malheureusement c'est
contrairement le couple exécutif
n'existe plus on le voit bien au début
il y a un vrai couple exécutif où il y
en a un qui prend les coups l'autre qui
décide qui prend un peu de recul là
aujourd'hui au fur et à mesure du temps
dans le film on le voit bien dans le
documentaire c'est que en fin de compte
tout revient de plus en plus sur le
président à l'Élysée Saint-Honoré et
quasiment plus avenue bar rue de Varenne
quoi ça c'est vraiment le le je crois
que la c'est l'évolution la plus forte
ce qu'on retient aussi c'est qu'il faut
faire preuve de souplessement et donc
d'humilité peut-être Jérôme cordelier
oui dans un contexte on est isolé c'est
à dire que souvent on dit dès qu'on
rentre à l'Élysée enfin tous les les
locataires comme on dit de l'Élysée
l'ont dit à la minute même où on rentre
à l'Élysée on est de plus en plus isolé
donc c'est là où d'ailleurs François
Hollande le dit très bien il faut qu'on
garde des capteurs il y a pas seulement
les notes de préfet il faut aussi qu'on
ait des gens qui nous indiquent un peu
le le l'humeur et l'humus du pays quoi
donc il y a ça l'isolement moi ce que je
retiens aussi de ce formidable
documentaire avec un casting de rêve on
l'a déjà dit plusieurs fois mais c'est
aussi espèce de ce qui n'est pas trop
montré dans le spectacle politique si je
puis dire au sens noble du terme c'est
la trouille en fait la trouille de
l'événement qu'on n'aurait pas prévu
puisque l'art de gouverner c'est de
prévoir mais on peut pas tout prévoir et
là c'est la trouille donc c'est un peu
certains ont exprimé le fait qu'ils
avaient eu peur face à cette
contestation
alors je parle sous le contrôle de
Franck levrier mais je trouve que le
Nicolas Sarkozy dans ce documentaire le
montre très bien c'est à dire ce côté un
peu la peur quand il raconte l'histoire
avec la bassine qui déborde et la petite
goutte d'eau qui va faire changer tout
et puis on le voit sur un film
physiquement puisque alors ça c'est le
la prouesse de la réalité c'est que on
arrive à voir on a l'impression que
Nicolas Sarkozy ré endos les habits du
président et reando cette espèce de de
peur qui est l'événement qu'on n'a pas
prévu et qu'on n'a pas pu prévoir parce
que personne peut prévoir un mouvement
de foule
par exemple effectivement l'exemple
Malik ou c'est Kin a absolument
vraiment prévalu sur tout le reste
à tout moment un président de la
République a peur d'une affaire de ce
genre 68 on l'a évité mais tout le monde
a dit que le préfet Grimaud était
absolument exceptionnel mais là
l'histoire de Malik ou c'est Kin qui est
tué alors qui n'est pas manifestant
qui est tué dans une couronne là chacun
du coup chacun des présidents s'est mis
à dire voilà c'est ça qu'il faut éviter
en premier ce qui donne donc une
conception du maintien de l'ordre plus
compliqué on n'est pas détente face à ça
et qui donne la trouille comme le dit
Jérôme cordelier effectivement donc et
qui est en plus maintenant ça devient
quand il y a des jeunes dans une
manifestation effectivement tous les
présidents ont peur que la jeunesse
entraîne et d'ailleurs c'est François
Hollande qui parle beaucoup de la
jeunesse on va y venir je voudrais juste
qu'on regarde un extrait parce que
l'histoire de la Cinquième République
nous offre tout un panel de réaction de
Gaulle qui joue avec du génie disons-le
le président disparu et qui panique un
peu les Français il y a eu aussi des
propositions de référendum des retraits
de textes litigieux parfois de
l'entêtement donc quelle est la bonne
méthode il y en a-t-il une écoutez ce
que préconise François Hollande dans ce
film
il faut à tout prix éviter qu'un
mouvement ou dégénère ou se produisent
et se développe et il vaut mieux donc le
dialogue tant qu'il est possible
la négociation plutôt que
la violence et un moment la rupture la
peur de François Hollande c'est la
rupture du dialogue et le fait que les
jeunes implique aussi dans un mouvement
Patrice pour les jeunes tous les
présidents depuis de Gaulle en 68 ont eu
peur de la jeunesse ça c'est ça c'est
clair parce qu'il considère que elle
fédère autour d'elle les familles la
sympathie on met 68 la bourgeoisie
française elle était favorable au
mouvement en tout cas pendant un bon
moment comme dit leur voiture ont brûlé
absolument exactement
après le le contact là
[Musique]
c'est un problème de tactique politique
et d'opportunités François Hollande il a
choisi de reculer la loi sur la loi el
khomri sur un point parce que vraiment
la CFDT le lui a demandé
il faut un peu de grammouth dans ces
cas-là en l'occurrence dans le dans le
la loi actuelle celle qui a été
promulguée il y a une quinzaine de jours
il y a pas énormément de grains à moudre
ou bien le Président il retire
la retraite à 64 ans ou de la maintient
mais il y a pas de trucs intermédiaire
voilà et tout et toute la terre
syndicale et l'opinion publique
française souhaite le retrait des 64 ans
point il y a pas de négociation sur
autre chose donc c'est c'est les
situations sont quand même différentes
d'un président à un autre la rupture du
dialogue c'est ce qu'il faut éviter à
tout prix comme le dit François Hollande
bien sûr c'est essentiel mais moi j'ai
vécu avec Nicolas Sarkozy qui ont été
président de la République j'ai
travaillé avec lui mais j'ai travaillé
aussi avant il avait été très
observateur et on le voit dans dans ce
qu'il dit dans le documentaire très
observateur de des pères il avait vu
comment avait essayé de gérer à la fois
l'un Juppé sur l'histoire de 95 moi
j'étais au ministère de la Fonction
publique à l'époque je me rappelle très
bien et le choix entre assurance maladie
etc et le débat sur la sécurité sociale
mais aussi Jacques Chirac dans les
crises et même généralement le hall donc
je pense que quand on se nourrit de tout
ça on arrive quand même un peu préparé
comme président de la République en tout
cas c'est c'est le climat qui est
intéressant parce que à chaque fois il y
a quand même des points communs et on le
voit bien on peut pas gérer une crise
avec un seul coup c'est un rasoir à
plusieurs lames on le voit sur De Gaulle
on citer l'épisode de 68 ou il faut de
l'âme pour arriver à la fin des
manifestations voilà et puis il y a un
autre contact qui est intéressant dans
le film aussi qu'on repose que je trouve
que parfois on les observateurs le
soulignent pas c'est le contexte
international parce qu'ils sont happé
aussi par l'International on le voit
bien Pompidou est un Afghanistan au
moment des événements de 68 de Gaulle
part en Roumanie donc tout ça fait que
ça crée des distances par rapport au
phénomène franco-français et quand ils
arrivent ils sont surpris par la tension
surtout à l'époque où les moyens de
communication étaient pas les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui moi j'ai vu gérer des
grèves à la Sorbonne de l'avion
présidentielle à l'époque c'était pas le
cas les gens ne sont même se fichu ou
pas c'est vraiment le message qu'on
retient aussi c'est toujours le problème
des jeunes c'est comme un jeune c'est
pas stable donc on n'arrive pas à le
mettre dans une case donc c'est pour ça
en fin de compte quand vous êtes au
pouvoir vous craignez énormément ceux
que vous n'arrivez pas à mettre dans des
cases parce que vous savez pas comment
ça va évoluer comment ça va bouger
comment ça va réagir de ce point de vue
c'est vrai que la disparition des partis
politiques est importante parce que
avant quand on dit il faut on a des
capteurs les partis politiques comme le
Parti socialiste à l'époque comme le
Parti communiste comme le RPR et était
profondément des capteurs eux ils
voyaient les secrétaire fédéraux voyez
tout le monde et ça ça n'existe plus et
je trouve que c'est cette disparition
qui a entraîné un dommage collatéral qui
est effectivement peut-être c'est la
rupture entre la base et le sommet et on
se pose la question à l'issue de
documentaire de savoir si la rue peut
être plus puissante que les responsables
politiques ne le pensent Jérôme
cordelier évidemment enfin une fois la
peur c'est la peur de l'élément
incontrôlable qu'on ne peut pas mesurer
qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser et ensuite
le problème c'est que je pense et on le
voit bien d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire c'est que les dirigeants
ont besoin de se battre un peu contre
eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire ne pas tomber
dans l'obstination d'un contrôleur
finalement contre leur ego leur orgueil
voir imposer absolument d'ailleurs le
mea culpa de Alain Juppé sur 95 est
assez intéressant parce que il dit en
fait je me suis un peu trop obstiné ce
que dit aussi Laurent Fabius sur la
guerre scolaire de 84 où il dit bon bah
finalement il y a un moment il aurait
fallu lâcher un peu plus tôt c'est
intéressant de voir parce que en fait
l'exercice du pouvoir on s'en rend
compte dans ce documentaire requiert
énormément d'humilité
d'humilité que j'évoquais en tout début
d'émission sont-ils suffisamment humble
est-ce qu'il faut pas être très tendre
une chose publique fuyante quoi il y a
toujours une question de curseur ça les
uns et les autres le disent que soit
François Hollande ou Nicolas Sarkozy
notamment dans le documentaire ils
disent il faut mettre le curseur au bon
endroit on a vu les discussions sur sur
62 63 64 même pour la ministre de
l'économie il y a l'histoire du vase
avec la goutte d'eau qui tu fais
déborder le vase mais c'est pareil c'est
toujours et ça c'est l'expérience qui
amène à parfois à pas faire d'erreur de
jugement c'est à dire de se dire bon la
décision on la prend à cet endroit là
parce qu'on pense que on pense que ça va
permettre de passer c'est à chaque fois
la question c'est ce que ça passe ou
est-ce que l'équilibre il y a autre
chose je crois qu'il qui crée un emploi
une rupture mais
vraiment quelque chose de très infosé
entre ce qui s'est passé en gros avant
le 21e siècle et après c'est maintenant
de gérer des crises comme comme l'actuel
avec les réseaux sociaux et les chaînes
d'information continue c'est pas comme
en 95 en 84 en tout cas ça rend la
gestion du conflit social beaucoup plus
plus complexe mais beaucoup plus fine et
pour reprendre ce que disait Franck
ouvrier beaucoup plus réactif quasiment
horreur quoi
par exemple c'est plus difficile selon
selon les cas c'est-à-dire quand on dit
on a besoin d'une recette à 64 ans ou à
62 ans on est sûr que ça fait pas
plaisir aux gens
c'est mais sauf à quelques-uns qui
imprimer en même temps
là ça bloque ça bloque la conversation
tout de suite à partir du moment où vous
avez des syndicalistes qui disent non
pas 74 ans et quelqu'un qui tient sur
les 64 ans est-ce que ça aurait suffi
qu'ils disent ah bah non finalement j'ai
réfléchi c'est 63 mais pas sérieux non
plus
c'est vrai que là sur ce plan précis
c'est tout recule et tout capteurs sont
difficiles j'ai encore donné non je
pense qu'en plus le pouvoir est diffus
actuellement c'est alors je pense au
contrôle de deux anciens patrons de
chaîne mais le problème c'est que le il
y a tellement de canaux de diffusion et
puis il faut quand même dire aussi ce
qu'il est certaines vérités qui
dérangent mais il y a aussi un pouvoir
de l'information qui est instrumentalisé
de l'intérieur par des gens qui ont des
positions idéologiques et qui mettent
aussi de l'huile sur le feu sur le qui
est instrumentalisent un peu la colère
laquelle est sociale et ça c'est de plus
en plus important faut quand même le
fixer autre dérive à surveiller de notre
part et puis qu'est-ce qui fait partir
un mouvement qu'est-ce qui est allume la
mèche voilà une question qui tarotte bon
nombre de dirigeants politiques de tout
niveau plusieurs réponses intéressantes
dans ce film mais j'ai eu envie de
retenir celle de François Bayrou c'est
le moment où il revient sur l'erreur et
j'ai même envie de dire le péché
originel de Jacques Chirac qui mène au
grève de 1995 écoutez
Jacques Chirac se fait élire sur la
position de Philippe Séguin
c'est à dire sur la fracture sociale et
même 10 égale le Munich social oui il y
a une fracture sociale forte et cette
fracture sociale s'appelle l'exclusion
en général celle de certains quartiers
je n'aime pas le terme de banlieue qui
vont à la dérive et une fois élu il
choisit l'autre orientation
l'orientation gestionnaire face à
l'orientation sociale
Franck l'ouvrier ça veut dire que le nom
de la rue la contestation sociale peut
venir d'un sentiment de trahison des
promesses ça peut être une mèche oui ce
que soulève François Beraud est assis
juste c'est à dire que bien évidemment
il faut des moyens pour gagner le
pouvoir et c'est d'autres moyens pour le
gérer c'est pas le même contexte la
conquête du pouvoir c'est pas l'exercice
du pouvoir il y a des très bons
présidents pour la conquête du pouvoir
il y en a qui sont un peu moins bons
pour la gestion des cohérent entre les
deux oui c'est pas le même métier pour
parler vulgairement c'est à dire que
bien évidemment
en conquête vous êtes en concurrence
quand vous êtes en gestion de pouvoir
vous êtes seul et et toute l'histoire de
l'isolement du pouvoir est intéressant
dans le documentaire notamment mais
c'est ça la difficulté donc bien
évidemment quand vous êtes en
concurrence il y a une forme de
surenchère cette surenchère là vous en
êtes prisonnier c'est ce que veut dire
François Bayrou et ça a été un peu le
cas de Jacques Chirac avec Philippe
Seguin au moment de la fracture sociale
etc on sait très bien c'était pas
exactement ce qui avait prévu de dire
Jacques Chirac pendant la campagne et et
quand il arrive au responsabilités
innomme le Premier ministre qui est
Alain Juppé qui est quand même un peu à
l'inverse de profil de Philippe Seguin
et qui va aller droit et il le dit très
clairement au droit au but sur l'état de
financier de du pays catastrophique et
on coupe dans bien sûr des réformes qui
vont être des réformes brutales ils sont
pas prendre en compte et il est obligé
de faire un remaniement un an après même
moins d'un an après donc c'est ça le
donc il y a toujours un contraste entre
la conquête et l'exercice et ça c'est
pas simple
on s'aperçoit que même quand c'est dans
les programmes puisque là par exemple la
retraite était bel et bien et même quand
c'est annoncé même quand on se dit après
tout on était lu pour faire son
programme il y a des gens qui disent ben
non c'est pas parce qu'on s'avance en
programme que ça doit que ça doit se
réaliser donc si vous n'êtes pas si vous
ne le dites pas avant on risque on
risque de vous le reprocher et si vous
le dites avant ça n'a aucune importance
mais ça Chirac est pas le seul exemple
non sur sur des personnes non mais sur
un terrain très différent le François
Hollande qui fait campagne sur le
président normal ça a été vraiment
quelque chose de très positif dans sa
campagne ça l'a beaucoup aidé et puis
quand il se rend compte que le président
normal il part en vacances en train à
personne n'y croit
que ça continue comme ça on rentre dans
les bagages
et donc au bout de quelques mois il est
obligé j'avais fait un autre
documentaire où je remarque héros avait
dit ce qui était son premier ministre à
ce moment-là non on s'est rendu compte
tout de suite qu'il fallait changer de
pied et ça a pris un peu de temps mais
c'est vrai que sur la conquête et la
gestion du pouvoir c'est deux choses
très différentes si on regarde de près
qui peut allumer une mèche si on regarde
mes 68 la lunette c'est rappelez-vous le
refus de la mixité dans les chambres
universitaires je me suis replongée dans
des archives la direction de la fac de
Nanterre rejette la demande de droit de
visite dans les chambres entre garçons
et filles déclarent au Monde daté du 18
mars 1967 que je cite cette mesure est
inacceptable les cités universitaires
étant peuplée en majorité de personnes
mineures et l'administration étant
responsable de leur sécurité je rappelle
en effet qu'en 1900 jusqu'en 1974 la
majorité civile est fixée à 21 ans donc
mai 68 par d'un tout petit rien est-ce
que ça veut dire que ce qui allume la
mèche c'est aussi un passif une
accumulation ou un pouvoir qui n'est
plus en phase avec la société pas un
tout petit rien qui peut être important
aussi pour enfin qui peut être un grand
tout pour
ah bah c'est plus que symbolique là on
est dans le et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
est un carnet mais 68 on est dans c'est
un phénomène de société quoi c'est la
société qui essaye de soulever une chape
de plomb d'un pouvoir qui est jugé
autoritaire en tout cas qui un ordre qui
les empêche un peu de vivre une liberté
qui est en train de se passer partout en
Europe parce que Mai 68 c'est pas passé
uniquement en France
que disait Franck louvoyer tout à
l'heure le couple il y a une date
essentielle en mai 68 qui est le 11 mai
68 Pompidou rentre d'Afghanistan et va
voir De Gaulle et arrive à le convaincre
alors on sera après que de Gaulle c'est
vraiment laisser convaincre parce qu'il
était pas d'accord du tout mais il
n'était pas à l'aise avec ce mouvement
donc il a laissé Pompidou décider
réouverture de la Sorbonne qui a été de
Gaulle ne voulait pas en entendre parler
c'est Pompidou qui lui a imposé c'est un
tête-à-tête un peu shakesperia un
dimanche soir et après il est allé faire
une déclaration la télévision à 23
heures qui ce qui dramatisait un peu
tout ça mais le rôle du Premier ministre
ça et le général de Gaulle ne comprenait
pas il faisait il faisait tous les 10
jours un déjeuner avec ses avec ses
petits-enfants qui étaient à ce
moment-là étudiants ou lycéens pour
essayer de leur disait son petit-fils de
Gaulle me l'a raconté d'ailleurs dans un
autre documentaire il disait bon
expliquez-moi parce que je comprends pas
qu'est-ce que vous lisez qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
c'est difficile de répondre je crois
qu'ils essayaient encore à votre
interrogation en fin de compte le
problème il arrive jamais de là où vous
l'attendez ça c'est un principe de base
en politique surtout dans des crises la
seule chose c'est que plus il y a de gaz
dans l'air plus l'étincelle peut être
déclenchée à tout moment c'est à dire
que on le voyait bien le phénomène de 68
mais comme celui de 95 c'est un
phénomène où la densité de tension est
de plus en plus forte et qu'à un moment
donné ça peut être un problème X ou un
problème y qui va brancher une crise et
ça vous le savez pas on le voit bien en
ce moment c'est un peu ce climat là
c'est à dire que on pourrait faire la
comparaison
c'est pas uniquement limité à la région
parisienne c'est dans toute la France
c'est une tension qui est assez forte
qui est en plus une tension
internationale autour de nous qui est
aussi puissant donc tout ça fait que ça
crée un climat qui est particulier et
honnêtement faut pas qu'il y ait de
faute de carte parce que sinon il peut y
avoir un accident et et on le voit bien
dans le climat actuel c'est un peu le
climat similaire à celui de 95 bien
évidemment comme dirait les juristes
c'est pas une comparaison mais paralysé
aujourd'hui elle est pas paralysée mais
le transport fonctionne quand même parce
que en plus maintenant il y a le
distanciel il y a plein de choses mais
68 c'est un peu la même chose aussi on
le voit bien si inaccumulation de sujets
sociaux de mœurs de de difficultés je
dirais d'intégration il y a plein de
sujets qui rentrent en ligne de compte
et là aujourd'hui c'est un peu pouvoir
on a trop beaucoup de réponses et on n'a
pas assez de réponses des problématiques
qui se posent on peut faire le parallèle
avec eux aujourd'hui
sauf que quand on dit que les dirigeants
ou les présidents ne sont pas conscient
c'est pas vrai ils le sont tout à fait
ils le sont tout à fait de difficultés
des gens ils savent bien que quand même
non leur serviettes ça passe mal ils
savent bien de notre côté qu'ils ont des
obligations
sur les marchés des obligations
européennes donc je trouve qu'il y a
quand même des gens qui croient ce
qu'ils font et qui pensent que oui c'est
nécessaire alors même si la société
jusqu'où c'est nécessaire et à quel
moment il faut dire bon bah tant pis je
renonce comme quand Jacques Chirac dit
moi je trouve que c'est un précédent
terrible dans le dans la gestion des
choses quand Jacques Chirac dit bon la
loi voté pour mulet je l'appliquerai pas
ça ça veut dire que ça entraîne
effectivement tous les mouvements
syndicaux depuis à dire et pourquoi il
retirait pas sa loi avant c'est bien
pour ça que d'ailleurs que Nicolas
Sarkozy explique dans dans le document
que il a dit à Bernard Thibault il était
à ce le secrétaire général de la CGT là
ça mais ça ne passera pas et du coup ils
sont effectivement ils ont voté contre
lui mais c'est fait pour ça aussi les
élections présidentielles et vous faites
bien ma transition puisqu'on va
effectivement écouter un extrait de ce
que dit Nicolas Sarkozy dans votre film
parce que quand il a conflit social il
faut bien en sortir quelle que soit la
manière un retour à la normale s'impose
mais comment comment sort-on d'un face à
face tendue entre la rue et le pouvoir
justement Nicolas Sarkozy explique sa
propre expérience de ça réforme des
retraites écoutez
le Premier ministre était plutôt 63 ans
la ministre des Finances avait même
évoqué 65 ans
c'est moi qui devait rendre l'arbitrage
c'est le président qui doit rendre
l'arbitrage j'ai dit ça sera 62 ans mais
tout de suite parce que je sentais que
ça passerait
mais je peux pas vous l'expliquer
autrement Michel cotta est-ce que
j'avais un raisonnement
avec petit un petit deux petits trois
non Michel Cottin
alors oui tout le monde sourit à ce
passage mais ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'il dit je sentais
que ça passerait et là on en vient à
quelque chose d'un palpable exactement
et de l'instinct c'est pour ça que dans
le documentaire il y a un élément qui
est très intéressant c'est le traitement
de l'isolement du pouvoir et de
l'isolement du président de la
République enfin bon enfin il existe pas
l'isolement
chacun a bien évidemment ces capteurs
comme la Sarkozy moi j'étais assez
réunion des 62 63 et François Fillon je
me rappelle très bien et moi j'avais pas
l'expérience du président de la
République mais en tout cas lui il était
déterminé pour dire que 63 ça passerait
pas et François Fillon n'était pas sur
cette ligne là c'est pas c'est fait de
façon tout à fait je dirais calme et
normal dans un échange mais on avait la
décision à prendre et ces décisions elle
a été prise parce que lui il avait aussi
eu des amis élus qui connaissaient
depuis l'âge de 18 ans je pense à des
mères de province qui lui avaient à t'en
fais attention à ça etc c'est tous ces
éléments là qui rentrent en ligne de
compte dans la décision c'est pas
uniquement un salon à une réunion dans
un salon vert avec les conseillers
techniques c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe c'est compliqué d'arrêter un
conflit alors parce que on sait pas trop
comment il va commencer puis on sait pas
vraiment comment l'arrêter finalement
l'idée de base mais mais au-delà de ça
c'est c'est parce que vous avez et c'est
là où ce qui est extraordinaire dans la
politique c'est qu'en fin de compte
c'est une réalité humaine c'est une
décision humaine c'est ce qui fait qu'il
y a pas de recette miracle on est au
début des missions il y en a pas parce
que s'il y en avait pas s'il y en avait
il y aurait pas de politique c'est c'est
parce que l'humain intervient et qu'à un
moment donné il fonctionne par rapport à
son expérience par rapport à ses
sentiments par rapport à au contexte du
monde voilà c'est tout c'est loin qui
rentrait est-ce qu'il peut aussi
s'arrêter quand on sort le carnet de
chèques et pardon pour l'explorer
l'expression un peu triviale mais est-ce
que c'est ça aussi qui peut mettre un
terme à un conflit comment on sort d'un
conflit si on n'a pas l'instinct si on
n'a pas les capteurs c'est vrai par
exemple quand on dit que c'est un cumul
une crise politique et une crise de ce
genre c'est un cumul au fond on parle
des retraites mais il y a aussi beaucoup
de beaucoup beaucoup d'autres choses il
y a le pouvoir d'achat et à l'inflation
il y a la crise internationale qui fait
un doute permanent quelque chose de très
anxiogène
qui a laissé des traces donc c'est
plutôt chaque
manifestation chaque à son
continue différent et il faut peut-être
effectivement
donner un carnet de chèques sur un
contenu et en même temps maintenir un
autre objectif mais bon c'est une
gymnastique difficile c'est encore de
lier non je pense aussi je réagissais à
ce que vous disiez sur la méthode je
pense il y a quand même un peu une
méthode c'est à dire je pense que le
l'hyper président a fait quand même un
peu de mal c'est à dire on se passe
quand même de cette chose qui existe
depuis qui était fondé par les Dominica
au 13e siècle qui est l'intelligence
collective c'est à dire que le problème
un pouvoir qui veut sans arrêt
centraliser et décider seul et bien
évidemment s'isole braque les gens
contre lui enfin c'est j'allais dire
c'est parce que vous avez entendu
Emmanuel Macron qui dit que c'est parce
qu'il ne sait pas assez impliqué que
finalement ça a dégénéré justement ça
m'a un peu fait sursauter cette phrase
parce que on se dit en fait il a pas
forcément tiré les enseignements de la
crise parce que s'il avait fait
un peu plus lâcher du lait sur la
décentralisation les corps
intermédiaires le fait de de garder des
barreaux locaux
débats c'est l'intelligence collective
concrètement factuellement oui
parce que je pense foncièrement que
notre pays il fonctionne de façon
pyramide et que tous les problèmes qu'on
pas été résolus ils arrivent sur le
bureau du président de la République
sinon Premier ministre les aurait réglé
sinon les ministres
d'autant plus depuis le quinquennat qui
a accéléré en plus cette centralisation
du pouvoir et vous n'y pouvez rien parce
que c'est toute l'ambivalence française
on dit à la fois le président de la
République décide de tout mais on attend
tout du président de la République il y
a 15 millions de téléspectateurs qui
regardent son émission ça veut dire que
c'est 15 millions de gens qui sont comme
intéressés par la parole présidentielle
d'une façon d'une autre donc c'est c'est
toute la difficulté mais faut pas se
leurrer nos institutions fonctionnent
comme ça elles ont été en 58 mis en
place après les expériences de la
troisième et la Quatrième République
pour centraliser le pouvoir parce qu'il
fallait un moment donné quelqu'un qui
comme on dit dans mon de l'audiovisuel
donne le cap final et le 4 final il est
donné par le Président de la République
il est donné que par lui parce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe dès qu'il y a
une crise et il faut pas se leurrer
c'est de rester encore adapté notre
histoire à un moment donné et même si la
décision est compliquée en général elle
est compliquée tous les sujets qui
arrivent à l'Élysée ils sont compliqués
il y en a aucun ou dans l'évolution des
institutions on sent bien qu'il y a un
besoin c'est que effectivement si on
garde l'élection suffrage universelle et
elle est très critiquée mais enfin 80%
des Français sont pour quand on les
interroge mais en revanche il manque une
relégitimation populaire pendant le
mandat les gens ont l'impression que on
est l'île président et après pendant 5
ans il fait rose il faudrait des
élections mi-mandat
c'est le référendum qu'on n'utilise pas
mais la preuve c'est de Gaulle utilise
les deux puisqu'il connaît très bien son
texte solution pendant
c'est court si on se met à dissoudre au
milieu c'est vrai qu'alors les gens à
peine de tendre s'installer qui sont
déjà qui sont déjà rejetés les créateurs
de la conclusion 58 il y avait pas
quelqu'un c'est une modification
il est passé il a autour de lui des tas
de d'états de l'importance et des tas
d'influence qui ont changé un peu gérant
cordonnier oui dans Franck levier vous
dites fonctionnement institutionnel les
problèmes arrivent sur le bureau du
président mais tous les problèmes n'ont
pas à arriver sur le bureau du président
c'est comme dans une entreprise le bon
chef et bien il se dit bon ben il a mis
en place les bonnes personnes il a des
corps intermédiaires qui lui permettent
de régler des problèmes finalement
on a vu quand même des présidents
récemment qui essayaient de se de gérer
un peu tout c'est à dire c'est un peu la
fait diversisation si je peux dire dans
la vie politique c'est-à-dire n'importe
quel fait divers bon bah le président
arrive
tous les présidents on fait une loi sur
le fait divers voilà donc
et c'est ça le un peu le souci c'est
qu'on a besoin de un peu de respiration
et surtout on a besoin de de corps
intermédiaire et une confiance
et à mon avis
avec le recul avec l'expérience pour
quand même un énorme problème parce que
vous avez des députés qui sont quand
même j'aime pas trop l'expression hors
sol parce qu'ils vont quand même dans la
séquence d'écription mais ici son maire
d'une ville moyenne etc c'est quand même
autre chose ils sont au contact
obligatoirement permanent presque
quotidien avec
les traces et ça sera ma dernière
question pour conclure rapidement si
vous le voulez bien les traces laissées
par un conflit mal géré est-ce que c'est
dans les urnes à l'élection suivante que
ça se passe soit parce que les électeurs
boudent les yeux soit parce qu'il vote
aux extrêmes ce jour aux élections
futures c'est évident mais justement ça
complique le cas actuel le cas actuel le
président ne se représentera pas et donc
ça pose aussi le problème de la
représentation possible euh ou du double
mandat du triple mandat un président euh
donc ça se jouera dans les urnes mais
alors bien malin et qui jouera au fond
le macronisme dans les urnes après ça
dépend de la nature des élections je
suis pas sûr que les prochaines
européennes puisque ce sont les
prochaines élections la réforme des
retraites et la gestion de la réforme
des retraites pèse beaucoup dans les
urnes mais ça je me tourne vers vous qui
est plus d'expérience infuse dans le
pays c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est jamais
immédiat ça des conséquences toujours
sur le moyen terme c'est à dire que vous
avez dans une tension comme ça vous le
payez pas cash vous payez un moment ou
un autre et puis après c'est la
conjonction de plusieurs difficultés qui
amènent à une décision personnelle de
l'électeur qui va dire j'aime ou j'aime
pas mais c'est jamais immédiat et on le
voit bien même dans une émission de
télévision quand vous faites une
émission de télévision faut laisser le
temps que ça infuse quand je vois des
sondages qui sortent quasiment leur
suivant ou le lendemain l'émission
télévisions c'est c'est c'est jeter de
l'argent par les fenêtres parce que on
le très bien c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe il faut que les gens parlent
ils écoutent ils comparent enfin la
France est intelligente
ce qui est difficile c'est que pour
reprendre votre expression du carnet de
chèque de d'autres présidents avec une
majorité large pouvait se le permettre
parce qu'il savait qu'à l'Assemblée il
faisait passer les choses au Parlement
sans trop de problèmes là la difficulté
du d'Emmanuel Macron c'est qu'avec sa
majorité relative ne voit pas très bien
qu'elle réforme structurelle il pourrait
engager dans les quatre ans qui viennent
faut qu'il trouve le moyen voilà c'est
c'est son jour c'est un autre sujet que
nous avons aussi traité merci merci en
tout cas à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi mission en
partenariat avec le point je vous le
rappelle merci Jérôme cordelier merci à
vous à bientôt sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]